and there a couple of different
approaches to teaching this class one is
to make it fun I really like to make
material as engaging and as accessible
as possible so especially if you have
relatively little experience and
algorithms you've just taken six double
oh six and these some of these
algorithms get really complicated and
they're hard to understand and you makes
you wonder how did they ever come up
with that and so I like to talk about
that in some of the lectures I'll kind
of give an idea of how they might have
gotten there it's like oh we could start
with this really simple step it's really
inefficient but at least it solves a
problem but then we add this extra thing
and this extra thing and eventually you
get to the really fast solution so it's
less of a mystery of how you got there
or how the original researchers got
there and I also try to remind students
when especially in the harder topics
that this is not easy stuff and you
should think about a little more you
know do the problem sets and you'll
learn it a figure it out at a deeper
level but a lot of this material is hard
and I think being honest about that
makes it more reasonable students don't
feel bad for thinking that it's hard
because the first time you learn it it
is hard but the whole algorithmic way of
thinking of setting up a problem what
should the input in the output be and
then thinking about all different
solutions for how to fill in the middle
I think is a really powerful perspective
and it can shape pretty much your entire
life but especially if you're doing
computer science
it's a really useful way of thinking and
I've gotten lots of letters later from
students where you know they're doing
some jobs some computer thing and they
ran into this problem and then they
discover and then they look back at
their notes and said oh this is the
right data structure I should have you I
should use now and they solve it and
they tell me about it and it's kind of
exciting to see years later that the
different the way of thinking and lots
of the solutions and techniques you see
in this class really are useful out
there in the world so it's a it's a
useful class to take
it's it's a relatively hard class the
exams are are challenging and we try to
make them not super challenging but it's
hard whenever especially whenever
creativity is involved it's hard to do
that live in an exam so students may not
perform super well in the class but
still they get the idea that this is a
way to approach problems and they
understand some of the techniques and
over time they can sort of fill in
whatever holes they left behind and say
you know seems like a problem where
dynamic programming would be really
useful this time I really learned
dynamic programming dynamic programming
is one that we actually teach both in
double-a six and o46 because it's really
it's conceptually weird it's actually
really easy once you understand it but
getting to the that point of
understanding is really tough so we
spend a lot of time on it so that the
idea is the more exposure you get to it
the clearer it will become I think by
the end of six oh four six they have a
pretty good idea but if not years later
if they come back to it I'm sure it'll
be a lot easier this this third time
around so yeah a lot of these concepts
are I mean the ideas are actually really
simple they're just hard to shift your
mind into that kind of mindset but once
you do things become really clear and so
hope is by the end of the semester they
they get there